Subhan Allah.
Beautiful answer. Next question. What
are your particular words of advice
regarding the on the occasion of Ramadan
approaching us?
>> My advice would be that every Muslim he
or she should make it a point that they
should make a resolution that they
should fast each and every day of this
blessed month of Ramadan. And we should
try and acquire all the benefits of this
month. And we should not waste a single
minute in this blessed month on things
which are and try and concentrate as
much as possible in remembering Allah
subhana wa ta'ala. We should try and
look for his mercy. We have to try and
ask for forgiveness.
We have to try and seek for his love.
And we have to try and increase our
piety, our righteousness and our
patience.
And our beloved prophet Muhammad
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said in say
Bkari verb number three in the book of
fasting had number 1903. Our beloved
prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said anyone who does not leave
the false action and false speech.
Allah subhanana wa ta'ala does not care
if he leaves his eating and drinking.
That means if a person does not abstain
from false action and false speech,
>> Allah subhanah does not care if you
abstain from food and drink. That means
your fasting will not be accepted unless
you stay away from false action and
false speech. And a beloved prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam he also said
it's mentioned in say
which is written in mustnat ahmed ver
number two page number 230 had number
7148 and it also appears in sunnai
chapter number five had number 21106
where our beloved prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said oh people
the blessed month of Ramadan an is
approaching
and Allah has ordained for you that you
fast in this month
and the gates of heaven will be open in
this month and the gates of hell will be
closed and the devils they will be
chained
and this month is the night
which is better than a thousand months
and if a person is deprived of the
blessings in this
He is truly a deprived person. So we
have to make it a point that we gain the
benefits of this blessed month.
Our beloved prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said it's mentioned in say
bkari volume number three in the book of
fasting had number 1901.
Our beloved prophet Mus wasallam said
that anyone who fasts in this month
with faith seeking the reward of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala all his past sins
will be forgiven.
That means if we truly with sincerity
fast in this month and seek the reward
of Allah subhanana wa ta'ala all our
past sins will be forgiven. Imagine it
is such an easy way to have our sins
forgiven of the past. And our beloved
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam also
said it's mentioned in say bkari
volume number three in the book of
fasting had number 1904 this is a very
long hadith which has basically four
points. Our beloved prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said that all the
children of Adam all the deeds that they
do are for themselves except for
fasting. Fasting is for me and I will
reward him.
And he further said that fasting is a
shield. It prevents you from sin.
And the person who observes the fast, he
should abstain from obscinity,
from yelling and from ignorance. And if
someone yells at him or abuses him, he
should say, "I'm fasting. I'm fasting."
And the third point a beloved prophet
said in this hadith is that I swear by
Allah in whose hand is the soul of
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam that
the breath of a faster the person who
fasts is sweeter to Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala than the scent of musk
>> and he finally said in this hadith that
there are two things when a faster is
happy and looks forward to it. The first
is when he breaks the fast and the
second is when he meets the lord Allah
subhana wa ta'ala
and further it's mentioned in the Quran
in surah n chapter number 24 verse
number 31 it says oh you believe
truly have faith in Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala and seek the bliss that means try
and enter Jenna it's mentioned in surah
akav chapter number 46
verse number 13 and 14 that those are
the people who worship none but Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala
and they are steadfast in faith the word
isam
they're steadfast in faith that there's
only one Allah and no one else and they
shall not have any fear nor that grief
these are the people who are the people
of paradise
and they shall be rewarded Ed for all
the goods they have done.
>> So this is advice for the people that
they should take the best of this month
and should not spend time on things and
spend their time in the worship of Allah
and remembering Allah subhana wa t'ala
and asking for forgiveness.